Speaker 1: All right. Many of you knew this was
coming. Even right wing Drudge Report is raising
questions about Trump dementia after a completely
deranged and outrageous speech in Wilmington,
North Carolina, over the weekend. Drudge Report
after Trump's completely dissembled speech
saying demanding Don and demanding Don. Yes, this
has now gone mainstream. Donald Trump holding a
so-called rally in Wilmington, North Carolina,
over the weekend, which we covered live on
YouTube, Twitch and Facebook. At the rally, Trump
didn't make any sense. And you absolutely have to
see some of the things that took place. Donald
Trump denied being a terrorist at the event.
Understand that a former president
is denying being a terrorist. That
is not normal in the United States.
Speaker 2: To falsely label MAGA.
Make America great again, maga. Remember what
you know they say maga maga maga. They don't
want to say what it means. It means
make America great again. Uncle Sam
supporters as they want to call us domestic
terrorists. You believe it? I'm not a dove.
But you know what? There's great anger in this
country right now. There's great anger in this
country. Never forget all of this torment,
persecution and oppression is not happening
because of anything we've done wrong. Right.
Speaker 1: Donald Trump, as usual, taking
no responsibility for anything but denying that
he's a terrorist. In another really weird moment.
Donald Trump said We have to keep America gay,
which was another one of these bizarre glitches
where you can tell that his brain and his mouth
are struggling to connect in anything that we
would call common sense. Just take a listen to.
Speaker 2: This great country. Remember,
I was going to say it's good to use an
expression we have to keep our country
great prepared, but it's not. I mean, for
some reason, it's just not great anymore.
Oh, dear God.
Speaker 1: We have to keep our country gay.
In all seriousness. It used to never be okay to
say the country isn't the best. Remember that
during the Iraq war, for example, during which
I started following and covering politics.
Whenever those on the left would say this really
makes the U.S. look bad, this invasion of Iraq
because of 911, even though they had nothing to do
with each other. After making a case with faulty
intelligence about weapons of mass destruction, it
makes the country look terrible globally. And the
polls showed it. And Republicans would say, no,
that's unpatriotic. You can never criticize this
country ever, ever, ever. And now it's completely
mainstream for Republicans in the Trump MAGA world
to say the country is no longer great. It
used to be totally unacceptable to say that
then Donald Trump does his N-word thing. And you
can tell that when Trump asks the crowd, Do you
know what the N-word is? They get really excited.
Speaker 2: The N-word, you know what the N-word
is? It's no, no, no.
Speaker 1:
Trump going, No, no, no. Before the crowd
starts yelling it out. And there were a
handful of black people there that who would
have would have probably not loved that. But
Trump has to tell the crowd, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no. I'm talking about a different N-word.
Speaker 2: N-word. You know what the N-word
is? It's no, no, no. It's the nuclear word. He
mentioned the N-word yesterday.
Speaker 1:
You can see one one black guy over Trump's left
shoulder, sort of nodding a sigh of relief as
Trump says, it's nuclear. Its nuclear. Everybody
sort of relax here. A very, very strange moment.
And then Donald Trump, again, just one of these
things where it's not clear whether his mind is
scrambled or the teleprompter is glitching.
Speaker 2: You know, everything they do is
disinformation. They say things and they keep
saying I'm saying I'm saying them as people
start even believing them or not believing
them. There's not a lot of belief in this
place with all these thousands of people
going as far as the eye can see. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Doesn't make any sense. And then
lastly, Donald Trump again playing the ominous
conspiracy music as he talks about how bad things
are in the country. In this particular case,
rambling about airports being dirty.
Speaker 2: I guess we are a nation who
has once revered airports are dirty and a crowded
mess where you sit and wait for hours and then
are notified that the plane won't leave and they
have no idea when it will. A nation where ticket
prices are through the roof, they don't have
the pilots fly, the planes they don't want or
see qualified air traffic controllers.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So anyway, Trump knows
very little about what's going on in
commercial aviation. He's flown private
for like 20 years. Bonus clip. Bonus
clip. One of the speakers before Trump.
Mention Joe Biden and the crowd immediately says,
lock him up. Remember, that's not due process.
That's not law and order.
Speaker 2: And
he wants to hire 87,000 more IRS agents to treat
all of his working families like tax cheats.
Speaker 1: By the way, remember, 55,000 of the
87,000 are to replace retiring agents. It's all
really not very scary when you know the facts.
Speaker 2: Come on, folks.
Unidentified: Markham, huh?
Look at.
Speaker 1:
Remember, it is not law and order to lock up
someone who hasn't even been charged with a crime.
Scary stuff. And the attendees are even scarier